Sam you were a consummate fiscal or
conservative think it's fair to say but
it's social liberal that's correct you
also had the honor I think I put that in
quotation marks if once having had
Donald Trump ask you for some money to
invest so you know Donald a bit yeah I
know Donald died he didn't ask me for
money asking to be his partner I didn't
think that was a good idea at the time
yeah what was that well just I didn't
think it was an appropriate decision and
I didn't think he and I would do well as
partners would he do well as president
ah I don't know but I would say that
everybody should not underestimate
Donald I think he's competent
accomplished smart I think he's a little
you know in often different directions
but I think he's you know a competent
individual um I don't think you know he
would be my choice for president god I
think that a lot of his views are more
extreme that I could be comfortable with
are those views handing this presidency
to Hillary Clinton as David said
conservative on terms of fiscally
liberal in terms of social views when
you hear some of the things Donald Trump
says whether it's about Mexico or
keeping Muslims out there are many
people who sit in the middle who are
basically landing in Hillary Clinton's
lap because Republicans are saying crazy
things well first of all uh you know the
fact that that some of the Republicans
are saying crazy things I don't think
necessarily is going to be determining
what happens next year I think that
there's a disconnect between the Talking
Heads and what's going on out there the
American people are extraordinarily
angry American people are
extraordinarily depressed American
people I mean the last time we had
anything like this in my opinion was
1979 then why doesn't the Republican
Party pull it together why doesn't a
grand pooh-bah say but but I think that
that the kind of statements that you're
referring to and and maybe the extremes
that I reflected are very much
reflecting how frustrated the American
people are
now and I think it would be a mistake to
assume what the American people are
responding to you today is what they're
likely to respond to four or five
geopoint we need to ask ourselves why
Donald Trump is appealing to so many
Americans because you guys are sitting
here in New York City and you're not in
Des Moines okay and you're not in in
Boulder and you're not all over the
country and you're not seeing the
enormous disparity that existed between
you know the coasts and the rest of the
country you have a lot of very unhappy
people and and I think this election is
reflecting it and I think be very
dangerous